IT'S NOW TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG WARS.
(APPLAUSE AND CHEERING)
IT'S SUMMER, WHICH MEANS THAT
PEOPLE ALL ACROSS THE WORLD WILL
BE FLOCKING TO THEME PARKS TO
RIDE THE NEWEST ROLLER COASTERS
AND VOMIT IN THE NEAREST TRASH
CANS, SO TO CELEBRATE, TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG IS REJECTED THEME PARK
RIDES.
UH, EXAMPLES MIGHT BE, UH, THE
MUSTACHE RIDE, OR... OR TEXTING
WHILE DRIVING.
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK, AND GO.
(BELL DINGS)
D'ELIA.
>> THE ELEVATOR RIDE WITH
SOLANGE.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS. YEAH.
(BELL DINGS)
WILL SASSO.
>> UH, IT'S A STALL WORLD, WHICH
IS A... WHICH IS JUST A BUNCH OF
GLORY HOLES IN A MEN'S BATHROOM.
>> HARDWICK: OKAY, POINTS.
YEAH, YEAH. POINTS. BRYAN.
>> THE R. KELLY SPLASH MOUNTAIN.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH. SURE.
POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
CHRIS.
>> BRYAN CALLEN'S CAREER.
IT'S A FREEFALL.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
>> THIS... OH...
>> HARDWICK: WAIT A MINUTE.
>> SEE? THEY'RE JUST LIKE THE
BLUEFIN TUNA.
>> HARDWICK: WAIT A MINUTE.
I NEED A JUDGE'S RULING ON THAT.
THE JUDGES HAVE CONFIRMED THAT,
YES, IT IS, INDEED, A FREEFALL,
SO I'M GONNA GIVE YOU POINTS,
CHRIS D'ELIA.
(BELL DINGS)
CALLEN.
>> THE ANTAGONIZED SHAMU
EXPERIENCE.
(GROANING)
OH! KILLER WHALE!
POKE, POKE.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT, I LIKED
YOUR SPACE. WORTH POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
UH, WILL. NO, CHRIS, CHRIS.
>> DELIVERING BAD NEWS TO CHRIS
BROWN.
(BELL DINGS)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS. WILL.
>> THE FUCK-A-TRON, LIKE THE
GRAVATRON, BUT WITH FUCKING.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH. POINTS.
>> YEAH, YOU GET IT.
DO I GET...?
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, YOU GET
POINTS.
>> YEAH!
>> HARDWICK: BRYAN.
>> UM, THE TUNNEL OF LOVE RIDE,
UH, CREEPY UNCLES ONLY.
(GROANING, APPLAUSE)
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, THE SMILE
SELLS IT.
NO, STOP IT!
YOU PUT THOSE PUPPY DOG EYES
AWAY, BRYAN CALLEN!
>> WHY? IT'S CALLED MILKING THE
AUDIENCE.
>> HARDWICK: OW.
(BUZZER SOUNDS)
BY MILKING, I MEAN, MILKING
THEM. TOO MUCH?
>> NO THUMB.
>> YEAH, TOO MUCH, MAN!